[موسيقى]
مفاجاه كبيره اعلنت عنها هيئه الافلام
خلال ايام مهرجان البحر الاحمر السينمائي
الدولي وهي تحويل مسابقه الضوء الى مبادره
طوال العام في اي وقت لدعم الافلام بمبالغ
ماليه غير مشترده مبالغ انتاجيه ماليه هذه
المبادره تحمل الكثير من المفاجات لرفع
مكتبه الانتاج السينمائي السعودي وزياده
عدد الافلام وايضا لرفع جوده الافلام
المحليه
[موسيقى]
طبعا احنا هنكون حريصين في عمليه الاختيار
بشكل مره جيد عندنا اللجنه من الخبراء
المحليين والعالمين والاقليين اللي راح
يقيمون كل عناصر الفيلم ونحنا في نفس
الوقت واثقين في المنتج السعودي لانه ما
راح يشتغل معنا للمنتج او المخرج السعودي
اللي شفناه لتجاره السابقه ناجحه ومميزه
هذا ما يقال الاشياء
واثقين ان شاء الله بالمنتج السعودي نكون
جدا مميز
[موسيقى]
هنالك خطوات لضمان جوده العمل الاول الدعم
يقدم على شكل خطوات متروسه متابعه من
الفريق لانه في النهايه نهدف الى رفع
مستوى جوده الفيلم دون التدخل في النظره
نريد ان يكون مستقلين تماما لكن ايضا اريد
ان ان نتاكد ان ما قدم في العرض الفنيه
يتحقق فيها المشروع
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]